We all have questions
that keep us up at night.
Here are two of mine.
The first is: What makes us human?
In a world where
human beings and technology
are increasingly converging
and where with the power
of virtual reality
we can embody anything we want,
what is it that continues
to keep us human?
Now there's loads
of different answers to this,
but the social anthropologist in me
hangs on to the human power
of forethought.
That's our ability to predict
and prepare for what might happen.
Of all the things
that make us uniquely human,
forethought has got to be
one of the most interesting
because it enables us
to imagine and create our futures.
It gives us the ability
to be deeply creative.
My next question is:
Are we living in reality?
I'm not channeling my inner Morpheus here.
This is honestly something
I think about a lot.
I think about how we’re moving towards,
or perhaps have always been,
living in multiple levels of existence.
After all, simulations aside,
reality is really just
the stories we tell ourselves
about what we think we see around us
and may be influenced
by other people’s stories.
And so every story that you
have ever heard or ever will,
including the one
I'm about to tell you now,
will influence your version of reality.
When I was five years old,
I was obsessed with "Alice's Adventures
in Wonderland" by Lewis Carroll.
I loved how impossible it was,
and yet real at the same time.
Back then, this was my virtual reality.
And there's an exchange in the book
between Alice and the White Queen,
where the queen is saying
that if you try hard enough,
you can believe in anything,
whether it's possible or not.
So now, even though I consider myself
a pretty pragmatic person,
I too try to believe
in six impossible things before breakfast.
And with the power of virtual reality, VR,
I can often make them a reality.
But as you get older,
your imagination takes a bit of a knock
and you lose that childlike wonder.
There's bills to pay
and kids to keep alive
and work to be done.
And then there's
the monotony of boardrooms
and PowerPoint presentations
and video calls.
Hmm.
Now, I've been lucky to work remotely
for a lot of my career,
and it is amazing
for so many different reasons.
Without all of the technology
we have today,
remote work would be impossible.
But our overreliance on video calls
is hurting our ability
to be creative as a team.
And this is a big problem
because creativity
isn't just for artists and musicians.
It's what drives innovation
in our workplaces.
And without it, we can't solve
the many problems we face as humanity.
Now you may have been told
to turn your camera on during video calls
so that people can
more easily connect with you.
This makes a lot of sense
on the surface level
because nobody likes
speaking to a blank screen.
But research done
by Carnegie Mellon University
has found that turning our cameras on
during video calls
impacts our ability
to do creative teamwork.
Now if you're anything
like me on a video call,
your attention is very divided.
You're trying to look
at people's facial expressions,
usually, which you can't quite make out.
You're trying to listen
to what people are saying,
but you're also looking at yourself
and making sure
you've got no food on your face.
And it just doesn't feel
like a very natural way to communicate.
And it's not.
For millennia, our human ancestors,
who have evolved to be creative
just in order to survive,
have done so in 3D environments.
That's just how our brains are wired.
It's only been relatively recently
that we've been distracted
by these glowing 2D screens.
And these screens
are designed to display things.
It's called display
technology for a reason.
We were never meant
to communicate through them.
So if video calls are confusing
and they hurt our creativity,
then why are we still using them?
And when I asked this question,
the answer I get is usually the same.
People say it's the best we have
or it's the closest thing
we can get to real life.
So this got me thinking.
Are video calls really the best we can do
with all of the technology of today?
And what's so good about real life anyway?
What if, rather than
trying to recreate reality,
we aimed for something better?
Now there's already a multibillion-dollar
industry devoted to just this,
instantly transporting you somewhere else
and enabling you
to be present and creative
with people from around the world.
And that is the games industry.
Many games are laying the foundation
for the metaverse,
and we've heard quite a lot
about this metaverse recently.
I like to think of it as an evolved 3D
and experiential version of the internet.
To give you an example.
Brands currently have websites
and social media pages.
In the metaverse,
these brands may also have
experiential immersive spaces
that you can visit and engage directly
with whatever they're selling.
So the metaverse is providing
these new social creative spaces.
So if you find yourself worrying
that your child
is playing too much Minecraft
or Roblox or Fortnite,
you can remind yourself
that these are not just games.
They're hanging out with their friends.
They’re practicing important life skills
like empathy and teamwork.
And they’re often creating
and innovating in these spaces,
far more, dare I say, than you or I are
on our fourth video call of the day.
Virtual reality, whilst it's not
synonymous with the metaverse,
is one of the most powerful technologies
we can use to access these spaces.
And I believe with the power of VR,
the metaverse will reignite
workplace creativity
and inspire us to achieve the impossible.
But let's take a step back here.
The three key features of virtual reality
can be said to be immersion,
interaction and imagination.
I like to call them the “three magic I’s.”
And the cool thing
about the three magic I's
is that they're also three key drivers,
I believe, of creative
collaboration as well.
So let's look at these
in a bit more detail.
The first is immersion.
Immersion by this definition
is when your senses are isolated
from your physical environment
and put into an entirely
different virtual environment.
And technology is coming on so much
that we won't just be able
to see, hear and feel things in VR,
but we'll be able to taste
and smell them too.
The “internet of senses” is here,
and it's completely revolutionizing
how we interact with each other
in virtual environments.
Immersion gives us copresence.
That's that feeling
of really being there with others.
And our brains don't know the difference
between virtual reality
and reality reality
when it comes to copresence,
so we can be together psychologically,
even when we're apart.
And this enables
social creativity to thrive.
The second magic I is interaction.
And interaction is where you can
manipulate things within your environment
that isn't really there.
So when we design physical products,
we imagine them in 3D,
we produce them in 3D.
And yet traditionally,
we've visualized them on 2D screens.
By using VR instead,
we can do this in real time in 3D
whilst being able to cocreate, discuss
and manipulate these designs
with our teams.
The third magic I is imagination,
and this is a biggie for me.
VR gives us the ability
to do anything and be anywhere,
regardless of whether it exists
in reality or not.
Maybe you want to speak to someone
in a different language
and have that instantly translated
above the avatar's head.
Perhaps you want to take your brainstorm
on top of Kilimanjaro
or write your notes in dust on the Moon.
And yet, with all of the amazing
possibilities afforded to us by VR,
lots of our virtual environments
still mirror our physical environments.
And there's a psychological
reason for this.
A concept called “structured imagination”
means that we tend to rely on existing
paradigms when we create things.
In fact, let's try something quickly.
I want you right now to imagine
an animal that doesn't exist
and be as creative as you can be.
Got something?
So even though I told you
to be as creative as you can be,
structured imagination tells me
that most people will have imagined
an animal with eyes of some form
and legs of some form,
perhaps not dissimilar
to Leggy McEyeface over here.
Maybe that's just me.
But we do the same things
when we think about our workplaces.
We think of an office as a building
with a roof and chairs and desks.
But we don't need a roof in the metaverse
because there's no precipitation.
We don't need chairs with legs
because the floor isn't really there.
In fact, we don't need chairs at all.
Do you think that's air
you're breathing right now?
And the problem with recreating things
like traditional boardrooms
is that we know
that stark corporate spaces
aren't conducive
to creative collaboration.
So what else do we know
about creative collaboration?
Thankfully, we know quite a lot.
We know that retreats,
breaking away from the day-to-day,
can help induce creative thinking.
We know that some time alone
for reflection
can help the team be more creative
when they come back together.
We can speak to color psychologists
who will tell you that gray
is not a great color
if you're trying to encourage creativity.
We know that nature,
the unexpected
and even messiness
can help induce divergent thinking.
So as we build our metaverse workplaces,
we can be inspired by our imaginations
but guided by all
of this fantastic research
that's been done before.
Lots of people ask me how far
we are away from a true metaverse,
and I don’t really have
an answer for that.
Or I do, but we’d be here all day.
But I will say two things.
The first thing is that
using immersive technology
is not the future
of workplace communication.
It's the present.
Organizations, large and small,
are already providing VR headsets
to their employees
the same way that they would
traditionally just provide a laptop,
to help their teams feel closer together,
to encourage trust
and to grow relationships.
Secondly, and importantly,
the impact that the metaverse will have
on various areas of our lives
will be profound.
And as with anything created by humans,
there's a potential for it
to be incredibly positive
or devastatingly negative.
Just as social media,
in the previous iteration of the internet,
gave a voice to the voiceless
and created jobs that didn’t exist before,
it also laid the foundation
for dangerous monopolies
and for misinformation campaigns
that have destabilized entire democracies.
So ...
We have an incredible
opportunity in front of us,
an opportunity to completely
reimagine work and how we collaborate.
But we must use
our human power of forethought
to create the kind of future
we want to see.
We must become conscious and deliberate
creators of our own destinies.
“Alice in Wonderland”
symbolized curiosity,
imagination and experiencing
the impossible.
VR allows us to do the same.
So here's my ask of every leader today.
Let's put on our VR headsets
and follow that white rabbit.
Let's chase our curiosity
to impossible places in the metaverse
where anything can happen --
and where we can solve humanity's
biggest problems together.
Thank you.
(Applause)